transcriptomics three is a course
dedicated to advanced methods of
analysis that will allow us to find
meaningful patterns and data especially
complex patterns that are present in big
data sets the course builds upon what we
learned in transcriptomics 1 & 2 in
transcriptomics 1 we learned how to
convert raw reads from a next-generation
sequencer into a table of expression and
then visualize it to develop a
hypothesis in transcriptomics 2 we
looked at statistical methods for
determining differentially expressed
elements that are present in known
groups of samples we explored the
students t-test bayesian methods such as
de 2nd magyar as well as factor
regression analysis that effect the
influence of multiple factors here we
will explore different methods for
identifying groups of sample without
prior knowledge a process called
clustering and then examine methods for
developing classification models from
known samples in order to classify data
and new samples we will be using an
example from the publication by Damon
among others this is modeling precision
treatment of breast cancer which was
featured in genome biology in 2013 this
publication is interesting because the
authors assembled the dataset of about
50 different breast cancer cell lines to
represent the whole spectrum of breast
cancer variations the cell lines have
genomic transcriptomics and proteomics
data as well as an efficacy measurement
of commonly used and experimental cancer
drugs this course will speak a lot about
data mining or the exploration analysis
of large data to discover meaningful
patterns and rules data mining
techniques are used to build machine
learning models that power modern
artificial intelligence applications
such as search engine algorithms and
recommendation systems the methods are
an important part of big data analysis
and are especially relevant to highly
detailed biological data data which has
indeed been growing at an exponential
rate
with unsupervised machine learning
methods we start with the data set
typically a table of elements such as
these shapes we can use a clustering
method for example hierarchical
clustering which is a method that seeks
to identify groups based on their
similarities or we can use a
dimensionality reduction method such as
principal component analysis that will
assign samples to groups of elements
that are present in some cases we can
use these results to draw other
conclusions about the data within the
structure in this case groups based on
the shape of elements within the group
this is new information that this
technique generates one such approach is
PCA that uses dimensionality reduction
to show us what the data variability
looks like in PCA we use the approach of
principal components that explain
variance and our data in the best
possible way here is data with low
variance the samples are close together
and here's a sample set with higher
variance
however this variance is not well
explained by the x and y axes but you
could draw a line to the original space
that shows the maximum variance of this
data set this vector through the
multi-dimensional space that maximizes
the variance of the data is called a
principal component and just like with
the previous example we can add other
principal components such as PC 2 or
even PC 3 thus visualizing our data by
projecting it into a space of two or
three axes that explain some percentage
of data variance when we select the
principal components that explain the
most variance of our data we can reject
all of our samples into this space and
visualize the full data set this
technique is called principal component
analysis and it can be very helpful in
the initial stages of our analysis
we can like in pca to a photographer
trying to find the best angle for a
picture that will capture as much detail
as possible
while showing us the most information
about the group as a whole
we would typically use this method to
visualize as well as explore our data
when using this multivariate analysis
method it's important to play around
with the data using normalization and
filtering while paying attention to
outliers for the best possible
interpretation the PCA does not identify
groups or their boundaries and that's
when we turn to clustering there are
many types of clustering and
hierarchical is one of the most popular
approaches because it allows clustering
on different levels so let's say we have
our samples organized in some space
imagine a PCA 2d plot where samples are
positioned in some perspective the best
represents the data variability the
algorithm would find the two closest
objects in this projection and then link
them together this is a cluster then we
would find the next two closest groups
of two where any two linked objects are
considered as a single object and their
location is the center of that cluster
the algorithm will run until all objects
are assigned to a cluster with all the
objects in it hierarchical clustering is
an example of an agglomerative or
bottom-up clustering method that starts
with attributing each sample to a
separate cluster it then finds the pair
of most similar samples and unites them
with one cluster that is further
attributed as one quasi sample this
procedure is repeated until coming into
one cluster that contains all the
samples the pipeline will take the input
perform clustering and put out the
result in several formats we will
discuss in a little bit in this course
we will explore various types of
clustering methods as well as their
parameters to see what the differences
are between them we will also discuss
how to best apply them to our RNA seek
data clustering is also widely used in
data visualization to organize the
patterns into heat maps so that we can
visually see groups of samples as well
Jeanne's we will also learn about
several methods of supervised machine
learning which includes classification a
supervised analysis technique that
relies on annotated or labeled data
supervised machine learning takes in
data that has been labeled typically
this is done by people in biomedical
projects this could be clinical data or
other phenotypic data the labeled data
is used the trainer model and the model
is tested on a test data set this data
set will include examples of what is in
the training data but might also contain
additional variation the methods will
vary as do the principles used to build
the model for now we can refer to them
as a black box the method is essentially
to learn from the differences between
various classes that are present in a
training data set
once this learning is established you
have a model or a template that can be
applied to new datasets new data will
have to be assigned with a class that is
present in the training data set so
something does not fit the model such as
the star on the bottom right model
accuracy will be reduced the output of
classification algorithms include
predicted classes for each object or
sample found in the data some algorithms
such as random forests also evaluate how
accurate and stable the prediction is it
does so by evaluating which features if
taken out are the most significant for
accuracy of the prediction one such
algorithm is called binary decision
trees their output looks similar to
hierarchical clustering with each tree
created by both thresholds and rules
binary means the branch can either be
yes or no if the expression of the gene
is higher than X the classes will
separate the algorithm will continue
until has effectively separated all the
samples into some group
random forest uses multiple instances of
decision trees that are applied to
portions of the data one at a time after
the analysis the tree predictions are
analyzed and majority voting is accepted
this algorithm is useful for more
complex patterns where smoother borders
between classes are needed it also gives
an output of most significant features
for classification another method we
will look at is linear discriminant
Alice's which is a method that is
somewhat similar to PCA but can separate
groups into defined classes it also
allows certain flexibility for dealing
with data variability another important
method we will talk about are support
vector machines this algorithm differs
from other classification methods
because it is optimal to find boundary
of a class additionally it uses feature
space transformation with the kernel
function
this makes separation more efficient for
example a circular class border can be
achieved by a straight hyperplane if the
space was curved in such a way that the
classes are cut by a decision surface
these methods are commonly used in a
variety of biomedical research as well
as clinical projects with large datasets
are beginning to be more and more
available these include patient
stratification disease classification
and mechanisms of both disease onset as
well as progression on the pharma side
biomarker discovery is an application
for classification
additionally there are other
classification applications such as
target discovery as well as drug
repurposing